respect a man that they make more money
than do you guys think I think it bring
when it comes down to actual household
because I know what you guys you guys
like to have like um subservience and
dominance kind of Dynamics I think that
gets very hard when there's an obvious
Breadwinner and I feel like
realistically whoever is making the most
money
ought to
they it will just naturally but
sometimes you don't have to say you know
like I've been that person that's earned
the most money and it's about you
respecting that person not to throw it
in their face either and it's about
there's certain things that you don't
even have to spell out like I'm on 55k
and you're on 25k it's just like okay
well what we'll do for the household
builds we'll go halves but I've got the
holidays and I've got the do you know
what I mean I think you can respect but
it's a choice it makes more sense when
you're more impoverished so when there's
someone that's obviously real like you
are dependent on them for rent and food
that's when the Dynamics you can't
really have that that's the problem yeah
it's the impoverished bit I think for a
lot of these things is my wait my mic's
on right yeah okay sorry I think for a
lot of these things I think it actually
depends on how the man carries himself
right I think that if you are so like
there's I think there's a similar
question in terms of like can a woman be
with like a below average height male
right there's a guy who might be five
nine who carries himself normally and
there might be a guy who's like five
nine who acts like he's very short all
the time and I don't think people won't
like that guy but not because he sure
because he thinks he's short same thing
with like in a household if the man is
making less money as long as the guy is
contributing well to the household and
he's not like being weird about it or
being like Moody about it I think he
could probably would you would you agree
that it's more of the exception rather
than the rule
are you asking me if I believe if
numbers are real and they exist or of
course it's the exception generally men
are more than women right now so
generally yeah no because I agree with
you because I have a lot of tall friends
like super tall like I'm not I'm not in
agreement in terms of I'm gonna say oh
Lord I want to bring culture back in
here okay black Caribbean culture
I'm gonna tell you the average man
versus the average black woman right now
the black woman is anymore is that in
the the Caribbean or is that in London
or what I'm going to talk about London
Caribbean okay I can't talk about
America I can't talk about where we are
now sure because what you were saying
about the is at the average yeah I
hardly meet men that earn more than me
yeah actually
let me qualify everything anything
business not legit man so do you do you
feel like you couldn't submit to a guy
that makes more than you okay less than
you sorry less than you oh yeah I could
but again it's how he carries himself do
you know what I mean I really think it's
about how you carry it yeah and if you
you might start from that position
because it's about money and when you
get into the relationship I think what's
mine is yours and what's yours is mine
maybe I'm wrong but it's one pot now no
and we're all just as well yeah
I first heard this conversation I was
always confused because I'm like don't
you guys have a joint bank account
doesn't it go into one that would be
ideal right yeah that's what I would
think that's right apparently people
have joined and then they have their
yeah they all found out later but like
when growing up everyone I knew always
just had a joint bank account but does
that mean you've got one foot out the
door then
I'm wondering in those relationships
where you have the joint but you also
got your little side monies
yeah are you fully invested in your
relationship yeah or is that your money
for a rainy day like for example I've
been told you have the joint for all
your main bills but then I have my money
to do my hair to do my nails to do my
you know whatever but
why can't I take that from the main part
I think you should stand this why you
just like pay bills pay each other
that's what I do like like I tend to pay
a little bit more rent because I outer
my partner so she'll just send me like I
think I rents like five grand she'll
send me like one or two thousand dollars
depending on what our agreement is and
then we'll just pay rent like that and
then everybody keeps throwing money and
they do their own thing but if you want
to do like a vacation or special thing
then depending on who's got the most
money who earns more again it's it
should be a team like you want to do
things together so like that's what I
would think like wasn't it but why
wouldn't you just have one bank account
if the problem the problem with One bank
account is we have to be really careful
about is it's easy to lose track of
spending and the last thing you want is
for money like easier to track it yeah
well it's just like it's a thing where
like nobody might mean anything bad but
maybe oh maybe I'll I'll be sure to I'll
say the woman maybe the woman loses
track of how much like hair nails
mani-pedic costs or whatever and then
all of a sudden the guy goes to check
his bank and he's like what the hell I'm
missing like you know 500 like what's
going on here and the woman's not even
thinking like oh I'm spending all this
money she's like oh I got you know this
material I'll spend it yeah and I think
that's the thing you got to be careful
of I think joint bank accounts can work
because be really really careful
tracking like the spending so somebody
doesn't like build resentment I think
you might you might as well just not do
it you think I I mean I don't think I
should I just think it sounds like too
much of a cluster yeah we wouldn't do it
in your relationship no really why not
because of what you just said I don't
want that confusion yeah like come on
man like my balance just decreasing
because of hair and those bags it's a
collective balance decreasing huh it's
the collective balance no but like it
still doesn't work I just think it's
confusion we'd have to keep receipts
track of everything like nah I think if
both parties are making a lot of money I
think it's okay because you guys are
rich or whatever but when you're like
paycheck man if you're like you know
three or four days out from Payday and
your account is broke and you want to go
out and get you know just like some kind
of food and then you go and check in the
last four charges where something your
girl did yeah you're I don't care what
kind of man you are you're gonna be
pissed even if even if you spent more
you're gonna be pissed off because
you're gonna see him like oh that's
gonna be tense it's gonna be tense who
do you guys think benefited more from
the women's sexual Liberation movement
or the sexual Liberation movement
I would say men men and it's annoying
because in any scenario men still always
benefit even before women got their
sexual Liberation men still benefited
now they've got their sexual Liberation
men are still benefiting I don't think
so I mean why do you think men benefit
I'm just curious the reason I think men
benefit is because now men don't have to
do a lot now to get sex so literally go
on a dating app a woman's coming even
now women don't even get their ears paid
anymore they'll be like I'll drive to
you because I need some D now what is
it's done now is creating unrealistic
expectations for relationships so now as
a woman you want a man to whine and die
new and 69 you
but I feel like now it's like men don't
need to do that anymore because you can
just get sex somewhere else is that
because I'm liberated or because
the Traditional Values have gone I think
live
living in the
primary manner that
upon obviously like I would
I would to an extent I'm sexually
liberated because of the fact that I I
feel like I can have sex with whoever I
want but this is the person that I want
to be with it's not just somebody that I
saw on the street and because he's fine
I'm gonna let him put something inside
me no it's because I respect this man I
want to see a future with him you know
it's somebody I actually see myself with
but I think a lot of women now it's just
I'm horny you know what let me give it
to any man and I feel like that is
stupid to just any man breath a lot of
women
I apologize
but I think like a lot of times like
you're saying yeah you're liberated and
all this but it's not like women are not
just going around throwing it to just
any guy out there because there's loads
of guys that are not getting any books
and you don't always forget that every
single time you have these conversations
for those guys yeah we always quote the
40 of men that are not getting sex right
yeah you don't care about you're not in
that category I'm really sorry but
Society already helps you like men that
you can get sex on a platter you can get
a prostitute do you know actually what
people never as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible